[Musique]
et cette invité aujourd'hui c'est vous
Hugo du minil copain bonjour bonjour fan
de Coolio
vous êtes mathématiques mathématicien
tout autre chose que ça n'empêche pas
d'écouter de la bonne musique professeur
à l'Institut des hautes études
scientifiques ici en région parisienne
et à l'Université de Genève en Suisse où
vous vivez vous avez obtenu avant l'été
la médaille field délivrée tous les
quatre ans dont on dit qu'elle est
l'équivalent d'une Nobel de
mathématiques la façon dont vous l'avez
appris est assez savoureuse peut-être
vous pouvez nous le raconter oui
effectivement alors on apprend bien à
l'avance on est sous embargo on n'a pas
le droit de le raconter et je l'ai
appris en janvier mais c'est arrivé dans
mes spams en fait j'aimais la pensée que
c'était un spam et donc je l'ai appris
quelques jours après
le jour vous n'avez pas toujours voulu
être mathématicien non effectivement
quand j'étais jeune je voulais être
d'abord astronome après j'ai voulu être
joueur de handball professionnel
heureusement vu mon physique
d'aujourd'hui que c'est j'ai pas choisi
cette voix mais c'est beaucoup plus tard
au lycée puis en fait durant mes études
que je me suis dirigé vraiment vers
mathématicien donc plutôt une vocation
tardive et vous êtes de ceux qui ne
pensent pas qu'il y a
ce truc des maths et ceux qui l'ont pas
disons que ce que je pense c'est que
comme dans beaucoup de métiers créatifs
il y a tellement de paramètres qui
interviennent dans sa créativité qui
font qu'on ait quelqu'un de créatif ou
non que on peut pas vraiment résumer un
mathématicien une machine qui serait
particulièrement habile avec les nombres
il y a aussi il faut une sensibilité il
faut de la pugnacité il faut plein de
choses et du coup je pense que n'importe
quel individu a certaines choses en lui
et peut devenir mathématicien on va
revenir sur effectivement ce que vous
dites de votre métier et de cette
créativité qui je crois est importante
pour vous ce que la médaille field est
venue consacrer ce sont vos travaux de
recherche sur la percolation est-ce que
vous pouvez expliquer aux non initiés
que nous sommes de quoi il s'agit oui
alors la percolation en fait c'est un
modèle comme une caricature mathématique
qui permet d'essayer de comprendre les
phénomènes de porosité comme par exemple
est-ce que l'eau va passer à travers les
grains de café quand on est en train
d'essayer de faire du café donc c'est
c'est là qu'on voit le le terme
percolation apparaître mais c'est aussi
le même phénomène qui régit on va dire
les gaz qui passent à travers le charbon
ou dans un masque et donc on essaie de
comprendre avec des caricatures
mathématiques pourquoi certains
matériaux laissent passer par exemple le
gaz ou certains matériaux ne laisseront
pas passer le gaz et ça permet de
comprendre plus généralement d'autres
phénomènes de la vie courante et c'est
le jeu du mathématicien d'essayer de
faire des liens entre ces différents
phénomènes quand on les prend avec un
niveau d'abstraction on va dire
suffisant vous faites de la recherche
dites fondamentale c'est-à-dire que en
tout cas à votre niveau elle n'a pas
forcément d'application c'est ça tout à
fait c'est moi ma motivation en fait
principale ça va être plutôt l'élégance
des idées qu'on va créer quand on pose
ces questions ce qui est en fait une
approche assez complémentaire de la
recherche appliquée qui elle se dirige
et motivé par une application directe
mais les deux en fait ont une synergie
naturelle beaucoup de l'application
viennent en fait se baser sur des idées
qui au départ ont été créés par des
humains qui eux n'avaient en tête que la
beauté des idées qui essaient de créer
moi c'est une forme de
l'humanité de ce qu'on fait de mon point
de vue c'est un luxe vidéo de personnes
finalement auront la vie inverse qui est
mais ils se sentiront peut-être mal à
l'aise qu'il n'y ait pas d'applications
directes et c'est cette complémentarité
entre ces deux points de vue qui fait
que globalement en groupe en quelque
sorte on avance la connaissance humaine
alors on dit beaucoup de vous que vous
cassez les idées reçues sur les maths
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure elles
sont pour vous l'expression de quelque
chose de joyeux un de l'ordre du plaisir
de jouer avec son cerveau vous dites ça
oui il y a une satisfaction certaine
quand on fait des mathématiques et
d'ailleurs quand on regarde les enfants
en bas âge avant peut-être d'être
parfois malheureusement traumatisé par
l'école on se rend compte que les
enfants adorent les mathématiques qui
n'a pas essayé de compter le plus haut
possible qui n'a pas il y a une
fascination pour justement l'exercice
mental que représente les mathématiques
et c'est les mathématiques sont ancrées
en fait dans le dans le cerveau humain
depuis des millénaires des millénaires
et des millénaires et c'est quelque
chose je pense de fondamental chez
l'humain que de se poser ces questions
sur ces notions de nombres de géométrie
de représentation dans l'espace c'est
quelque chose de naturel c'est juste que
les mathématiciens d'un certain point de
vue ils ont gardé ça c'est des grands
enfants et continue à s'amuser avec avec
ses idées alors précisément la France
compte de très bons mathématiciens dont
vous êtes mais elle est extrêmement mal
classée dans les classes dans les dans
les classements internationaux comment
l'expliquer vous parler du traumatisme
de certains à vis-à-vis des maths il est
il est il est réel c'est une question
qui est compliquée effectivement on se
rend compte qu'il y a un décalage entre
l'excellence mathématique de la
recherche et le résultat des des jeunes
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut combattre
les mathématiques c'est quelque chose de
mon point de vue qui est une pratique
qui devrait être populaire et non pas
élitiste et donc c'est c'est malheureux
qu'on est ces niveaux là il y a des
tentatives qui ont été faites d'essayer
de comprendre ce qui se passait et de
d'essayer de modifier ça prend du temps
de modifier par exemple la façon de
d'éduquer toute une génération de jeunes
je pense qu'effectivement les tentatives
c'est d'essayer de replacer le plaisir
dans le dans l'enseignement c'est de
prendre le temps de de faire d'essayer
de il faut pratiquer les mathématiques
c'est pas juste de la théorie il faut
l'essayer il faut faire des erreurs
en France on les sait peut-être pas
passer aux élèves le droit de faire des
erreurs en maths maintenant c'est en
train de changer je pense qu'il y a une
réalisation effectivement que l'erreur
est à la et fondamentale dans le
processus d'apprentissage quel que soit
ce qu'on apprend et ça je pense que
c'est en train de changer ça prend du
temps de l'implémenter il faut reformer
les professeurs il faut prendre le temps
de faire ça donc je pense que ça va
finir par s'améliorer il y a une
réalisation réelle en particulier de
l'éducation nationale il y a un effort
fort qui est fait depuis le rapport
torrosion Villani et je pense ça va ça
va s'arranger mais c'est des choses qui
prennent du temps il faut vous savez il
y a 300000 enseignants du primaire c'est
une grande boîte
a précédé dans la médaille field sauf
que on ne peut pas vraiment vivre avec
son temps et surtout aujourd'hui avec
sans avoir des scientifiques au sens
large ça fait peser un risque quand même
sur la société tout à fait c'est de
façon générale je pense que le le la
piètre qualité de de du résultat on va
dire de l'enseignement mathématique en
France à la fois pour les meilleurs je
pense que c'est peut-être pas le point
le plus grave parce que les meilleurs
s'en sortent toujours un petit peu c'est
plutôt moi je pense pour la majorité que
il y a un vrai un vrai problème parce
que les mathématiques c'est avant tout
l'apprentissage du raisonnement or
aujourd'hui on a des une quantité
infinie d'informations qui nous arrive
des chaînes de toutes parts les réseaux
sociaux etc avoir ses capacités de
discernement de pouvoir
différencier un argument qui est
cohérent d'un argument qui ne l'est pas
d'avoir des notions d'or de grandeur les
nombres les probabilités etc aujourd'hui
c'est des choses qu'on nous envoie à la
figure constamment et ça sans parler
même des applications à l'économie etc
oublions ça juste cette habilité et
cette capacité à pouvoir réagir à
l'information qu'on nous envoie je pense
que c'est quelque chose de fondamental
et qui concerne tous nos concitoyens et
c'est moi c'est plutôt ça qui m'inquiète
que la recherche de très haut niveau les
meilleurs passeront toujours à travers
et arriveront au meilleur niveau mais
c'est plus cette capacité de
compréhension qui m'inquiète sans les
mathématiques sont le raisonnement
logique qu'elle permette au cerveau
d'avoir par exemple vous dites on ne
peut pas débusquer une fake news ça
c'est pas possible non exactement il
faut il faut des mathématiques il faut
aussi c'est complémentaires de tout
plein d'autres disciplines je suis pas
en train de dire que les mathématiques
sont la chose qu'il faut mais ça vient
complémenter l'histoire pour avoir des
notions justement de pouvoir replacer
dans un contexte le français bien
entendu toutes les disciplines sont
importantes et les mathématiques font
partie de ce package de discipline qu'on
apprend à l'école de d'éducation qui
nous permet de nous de traiter
l'information qu'on nous envoie et et
finalement de pouvoir faire les bonnes
décisions parce que la première victime
de d'un mauvais raisonnement c'est la
personne qui le fait en général les
maths peuvent-elles accepter le doute la
nuance ou l'absence de réponse je vous
pose la question parce que la crise du
covid a un peu malmené notre rapport à
la science et aux scientifiques
qu'est-ce que ça vous a m'inspiré en
fait les mathématiciens sont des gens
sont constamment confrontés à par
exemple l'impossibilité il y a quelque
chose en mathématiques qu'on sait faire
et il y a peu de disciplines qui qui
savent faire ça si on sait montrer
quelque chose est impossible on sait
dire tu sais c'est beaucoup plus dur de
de dire que on ne pourra jamais faire ça
plutôt que de montrer qu'on peut le
faire pour montrer qu'on peut faire
quelque chose il suffit de le faire pour
montrer que c'est il y a aucune
possibilité de le faire là c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué parce qu'il faut
arriver à exclure toutes les
possibilités imaginables d'essayer de
faire la chose en question donc les
mathématiciens l'impossibilité c'est
leur quotidien ils savent ce que c'est
donc on a une certaine forme de de
compétences à admettre que certaines
choses ne peuvent pas être aussi simple
qu'on ne voudrait en particulier quand
on est face à une crise comme le covid
et qu'on regarde le travail fabuleux des
médecins qui a été fait en particulier
pour le vaccin etc
nous moi pour moi c'était évident que il
y a des choses qui peuvent pas faire ils
peuvent pas vous dire tout de suite
c'est évident que il ne faut pas porter
de masse ou c'est qu'il faut porter à
masse ils ont besoin de temps pour
avancer pour faire le travail de
recherche qu'ils ont à faire donc ça
nous en tant que mathématicien on a une
capacité à l'acceptation à ce niveau là
et en particulier je pense que dans
l'éducation des mathématiques ce serait
bien d'avoir certains exemples justement
de preuves d'impossibilité pour montrer
la complexité de la chose que des fois
il y a des choses qui sont impossibles
et c'est dur à admettre mais il faut le
faire vous avez remporté la médaille
field avec l'Ukrainienne Marina
viaskovska elle est elle est la deuxième
femme à recevoir le prix depuis sa
création en 1936 ça n'est évidemment pas
la seule explication à ceci mais les
filles s'autocensure beaucoup on le sait
sur les carrières scientifiques et en
partie sur les maths comment on peut
inverser la tendance ça c'est un grand
problème effectivement parce que la
première chose que je vais dire et qui
est totalement évidente c'est que il n'y
a aucune raison biologique pour
expliquer cette différence c'est évident
à tous les niveaux on sait que ça se
passe après ça se passe dans dans la
société il y a une censure une vision
que les les femmes ne seraient pas aussi
apte que les hommes à faire des
mathématiques c'est totalement faux et
il faut le combattre alors nous on
essaye au niveau de la communauté de le
combattre pour en favorisant justement
le les femmes essayer de enfin en ayant
des programmes pour essayer de favoriser
les femmes vis-à-vis
on va dire de certaines obligations le
fait d'être mère etc on a tous
conscience je veux dire je suis devenu
papa je vois bien que ça implique des
choses pour ma femme qui sont pas les
mêmes que pour moi donc c'est important
de favoriser ces choses là mais en fait
il y a aussi tout ce qui se passe avant
sur lequel nous dans le milieu
académique nous n'avons pas de contrôle
et en fait ça se passe bien avant c'est
à dire que même à l'école primaire il y
a une les femmes les petites filles ont
parfois une vision de leur niveau en
maths qui est totalement
erroné en fait elles ont le même niveau
que les petits garçons mais elles ont un
sentiment de d'échec ça il faut arriver
à combattre ça c'est un problème en
mathématiques et dans plein d'autres
disciplines parce que encore une fois et
je le répéterai jamais assez il n'y a
strictement aucune raison j'ai des
collègues mathématiciennes absolument
extraordinaires marina est une femme
extraordinaire que j'apprécie énormément
et j'espère qu'elle va montrer cet
exemple du fait que en tant que que
femme on peut être mathématicienne on
peut être scientifique et on réussira
aussi bien que les hommes voient mieux
voilà n'ayons pas peur des maths merci
beaucoup
Hugo du